las vegas à vivre donc jusqu'à dimanche
à schiltigheim où partout en balade à
travers le haut rhin à bord du médiabus
sa présent nombre d'habitants du
département le connaissent ceux qui
n'ont pas de mediatek près de chez eux
chaque mois il marque l'arrêt dans 247
commune géraldine gruyère bernhard sch
des mers
[Musique]
rue d'alsace vous propose aujourd'hui
d'embarquer dans un média bulls l'un des
cinq véhicules qui circulent sur toutes
les routes de département et toute
l'année pour apporter des livres des
disques des films à emprunter c'est un
service du département qui tend à
disparaître en france mais qui ici dans
le rhin continue et fait plaisir à de
nombreux habitants
c'est au magasin que se prépare chaque
tournée on pioche dans le fonds de la
médiathèque départementale du haut-rhin
renouvelle terre a presque terminé sa
cargaison le bibliothécaire récupère les
derniers ouvrages embarquer les
commandes parfois gourmande donc il ya
des gros lecteurs effectivement donc mam
wagner effectivement qu'il ya tout plein
de réservations madame wagner on va les
retrouver j'espère parce que si nous
faut que je reporte tous ces mails ou
une centaine ouvrages ont été commandés
dans quatre villages renouvelle terre
cette équipe ce jour là avec laurent
grill chauffeur est bibliothécaire
la tournée numéro 36 naviguent au large
de colmar connais l'importance qu'on va
manger aux beaux jours arrivent au
ouais tu connais sa pizzeria marfain
l'avant à chaque fois c'est
un petit départ en voyage coixet
on s'en lasse pas le voyage c'est un
paysage qui défile et des rencontres le
média bus ne s'arrête qu'une fois par
mois dans les villages sans médiathèque
un rendez-vous à ne pas manquer pour les
lecteurs
ont déposé par et à chaque étape ils
sont là avec leurs gros sac on emprunte
autant qu'on veut parmi les 3000
ouvrages mis à disposition dans le bus
aménagé au fond l'espace jeunesse a
aussi ses adeptes personne ne monte dans
le bus par hasard tous les mois on bien
voilà et vous repartez avec combien
d'ouvragés une vingtaine
les histoires d'histoire c'est
intéressant pour nous c'est très
intéressant parce que c'est un service
qui est gratuit lord aujourd'hui où tout
se paye n'est ce pas pouvoir et en plus
ici on vous offre le conseil graphismes
ont testé le plus tôt
parce qu'ici la marchandise est fraîche
les dernières parutions ont complètement
leur place dans les rayons françois
mitterrand tient on à retrouver madame
wagner la très grande lectrice ou gandhi
gandhi aussi de 2,2
elle est venue chercher sa très grande
commande et même un peu plus
axé mon bonheur faille est pour
aujourd'hui nous
alors là c'est vraiment
absolument elle va tout le monde est
content
les abonnés affirment tous trouvé
exactement ce qu'ils cherchent du livre
au disque preuve que la sélection des
ouvrages et bien pensé y compris pour
les plus exigeants comme ce grand
amateur de science fiction ce sont des
auteurs qui sont connus d'autres moins
connus de la sf ou prenez certains
auteurs qui ne seront que vous trouvez
option pour librairie sauf allait
commander mon fait trouve ici
des petites pépites ici il ya des
petites pépites et a même beaucoup des
pépites qui vagabonde au gré des 45
tourner sur l'ensemble du département et
les rendez vous ne se ressemblent pas
selon les villages et le calendrier
scolaire bonjour
ya des moments où l'os bousculent et
d'autres où l'atmosphère est tout feu
très propice au dialogue tiens c'est ce
qu'ils offrent
alice au pays des merveilles
waziers l'histoire pyjama
ce contact particulier avec le public
cette convivialité qui s'installe de
façon spontanée les bibliothécaires ils
sont particulièrement attachés qu'on
voit d'habitude on papote on a quatre le
média bus ce n'est pas qu'un bus qui
circulent avec des micros
c'est un lire dans les villages il ya
plus rien il ya plus de boulangerie est
souvent plus d'école
le bureau de poste a fermé la mairie a
ouvert quatre heures par semaine enfin
voilà le bibliobus lui bien à personne
ouais ce service public de proximité
perdure dans le haut-rhin et c'est une
originalité
parfois le média bus accueille aussi des
artistes musiciens ou écrivains tous
dans le bus et c'est ainsi que s'achève
votre routes d'alsace et si dans les
prochains jours vous croisez les médias
bus n'hésitez pas à y monter on vous y
accueillera avec grand plaisir